It takes a lot for a kid to steal the spotlight
from Deadpool, but Julian Dennison has a superhuman
amount of charisma.
A native of New Zealand, the young actor plays
Russell, the mysterious mutant at the center
of Deadpool 2.
It's a huge role for Dennison, a self-proclaimed
Marvel movie fan, but it's far from his first.
He's been in critically acclaimed indie flicks,
hugely popular viral videos, and one of the
most legitimately entertaining body spray
commercials ever made.
Here's why the kid from Deadpool 2 looks so
familiar.
Shopping
Dennison was just a shy student from the suburbs
of New Zealand when the filmmakers for the
coming-of-age film Shopping came to his school,
looking for a young actor to star in the film.
Dennison's mom told Stuff that the filmmakers
narrowed down the search to Dennison or his
twin brother Christian.
The film premiered at the Sundance Film Festival
in 2013 and instantly turned Dennison into
a local celebrity.
He won Best Supporting Actor at the New Zealand
Film Awards, and credits the experience with
making him want to become an actor.
Blazed
Dennison's debut in Shopping didn't just impress
the critics, it also brought him one incredibly
important fan: Taika Waititi, the Oscar-nominated
director of the 2004 short film Two Cars,
One Night who would eventually go on to helm
Thor: Ragnarok.
Waititi thought Dennison would be perfect
for his next project: an extended public service
announcement about the dangers of driving
under the influence of marijuana.
The two-minute video for the New Zealand Transport
Agency features three kids who imitate the
antics of their stoned fathers behind the
wheel of a car.
"It's too fast!
It's too fast!
Take the wheel I'm freaking out!"
Dennison is hilarious throughout much of the
clip, but he also shows a hint of depth in
the final moments.
The commercial became a viral sensation and
generated headlines around the world.
"I love this music."
"What music?"
It also created a bond between Waititi and
Dennison that would yield another successful
collaboration down the road.
Paper Planes
Dennison's next appearance on the big screen
came courtesy of a supporting role in the
family drama Paper Planes, an uplifting tale
about a young boy in Australia who dreams
of competing in the World Paper Plane Championships
in Japan.
Dennison plays Kevin, a school bully who eventually
becomes the best friend of the main character.
Acclaimed Australian director Robert Connolly
co-wrote and directed the film with an impressive
cast that includes Sam Worthington.
While the movie performed well at the Australian
box office, it was far less successful in
the rest of the world.
Still, critics couldn't help but notice Dennison,
even in a smaller role.
The New Zealand Herald said he turned in a
"scene-stealing performance" as the reformed
bully Kevin.
"It doesn't get much closer than that."
Hunt for the Wilderpeople
If you recognize Dennison from anything prior
to Deadpool 2, it's most likely Hunt for the
Wilderpeople, the heartwarming comedy that
served as his official breakthrough.
Writer and director Taika Waititi didn't even
make the young actor audition for the role
of Ricky Baker, a juvenile delinquent taken
to live on a remote farm with a loving foster
mother and her cranky husband Hector.
"You can't read?
You're like one of those people who are like
raised by like wolves or something.
Hey, what's this?
This is woods.
Me stupid."
After a sudden tragedy leads Ricky to ineptly
attempt to fake his own death, he and Hector
go on the run into the New Zealand bush and
become the targets of a comical manhunt.
"S--- just got real.
Back up homies, and let go of my uncle."
Dennison took a month away from school to
work on the movie, but it was definitely worth
it.
Hunt for the Wilderpeople premiered at the
Sundance Film Festival and became the top-grossing
New Zealand film of all time.
It also directly paved the way for Dennison's
part in Deadpool 2.
Ryan Reynolds told The New Zealand Herald
the casting was partly a result of his friendship
with Waititi, who co-starred with Reynolds
in 2011's Green Lantern.
#YouGotSprung
After Hunt for the Wilderpeople made Dennison
one of the most recognizable people in New
Zealand, he put his star power to good use
in a completely unexpected way.
In 2016, he teamed with Air New Zealand for
a clip to celebrate the start of spring and
Random Acts of Kindness Day.
In a sort of Kiwi version of "pay it forward,"
Dennison traveled around the country to surprise
unsuspecting people with thoughtful gestures.
"I'm like Santa Claus, but in spring."
In the clip, Dennison pays for people's meals
at a restaurant, takes flowers and chocolates
to patients in a hospital, and gives out free
ice cream.
"So another awesome idea of ours to put a
spring back into someone's step is to throw
a banger ass party."
He ends the video by calling on New Zealanders
to surprise others with kindness, and we'd
be shocked if he didn't inspire at least a
few to do just that.
Chronesthesia
About four months after Hunt for the Wilderpeople
hit theaters in New Zealand, Dennison returned
to the big screen for a small role in a very
different type of movie: he played Beni in
the indie time travel romance Chronesthesia.
The film was made in Wellington, New Zealand
with next to no budget and a bare bones crew.
Chronesthesia premiered at the New Zealand
International Film Festival in 2016, but it
largely flew under the radar in America.
Summer Wonderland
In late 2016, Dennison showed up in another
video for Air New Zealand, and this time he
had a noteworthy pal.
In "Summer Wonderland," Dennison shows up
in a recording studio where Irish pop star
Ronan Keating is recording a take on the holiday
classic "Winter Wonderland."
But Keating doesn't make it past the second
line before Dennison interrupts.
"I'm gonna stop you there, Roman."
"Ronan…"
"it doesn't really snow down here at Christmas,
so…"
Keating eventually walks out, but the pair
soon work out a new version of the song that's
more appropriate for the climate.
Keating said in a press release that he signed
on for the project because he's a "big fan"
of New Zealand, but he also loved collaborating
with Dennison.
He said:
"Working with Julian was a breeze.
He's an absolute legend, incredibly professional,
and to top it off, he can definitely sing."
(singing)
LYNX Australia
If you want a video to go viral, it's become
increasingly clear that Dennison should be
involved.
The people at LYNX body spray must have known
this, and in early 2018, they teamed with
him for an extended commercial for their "Australia"
fragrance.
In the commercial, Dennison plays Humphrey,
a kid who doesn't have the best luck with
the ladies while his older brother Darius
is good at everything.
"He's just so chill and confident.
He can even talk to girls.
Strange behavior for a Kiwi, you know."
Darius eventually reveals his secret is LYNX
Australia.
The ad ran on TV and before movies in theaters
in Australia, but it reached audiences around
the world when it hit the internet.
Less than three months after it was released,
the ad had millions of views on YouTube.
"This was a bad idea."
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!